vous voyez le type d'organisation que nous avons
ici pourrait toujours utiliser un homme comme vous.
[ __ ] et puis ici, nous
savons où vous vivez, je n'ai pas les
compétences pour cela, je ne peux même pas me défendre,
vous avez les compétences, essayez d'
établir des relations avec ces gars, car les êtres humains
peuvent voir ce que nous voulons dire, mais juste
parce que vous '  Je ne regarde pas quelque chose, lâchez-
moi les mains, ça ne veut pas dire que ce n'est
pas là
[Musique]
qui pèse les gens comme
des terroristes massifs
ce matin en Amérique et il y a un
nouveau jour, comment pouvez-vous devenir des gars qui sont des
fanatiques, ils ne seront pas emmenés
pour le mal  au triomphe
qui ne prend que des hommes bons
pour ne rien faire